winnie the pooh entered the public
domain recently and so a filmmaker came
along and scooped it up
and turned it into a slasher horror
flick because this is i don't know how
all the laws here work exactly but it's
in the public public domain so they can
at least
make a movie with winnie the pooh
apparently there are so there's still
some copyright things like they couldn't
give him his trademark red
uh shirt so they put him in a flannel
instead um but anyway
the trailer for this winnie the pooh
horror film was just released let's
watch a little bit of that
you know you're the first person i ever
shown this place to and why am i so
special because soon will be christopher
and mary robin
we should be close now we're not going
to find them we will
poo piglet
eeyore we were friends for many years
and they're out there
christopher
we need to leave
now i really need to find out what's
happening here okay
you know
i i wanted to most people are having fun
with this i wanted to laugh at it
but
i actually kind of hate it i i mean it's
not serious it's not meant to be taken
seriously i i assume it's supposed to be
basically a joke
although it is a real movie that's
coming out but i kind of hate it because
just everything about childhood is being
perverted and destroyed it's all
corrupted and now they're doing this to
winnie the pooh
i mean not winnie
not not the poo first they got poo
scheissd now they got winnie all the
poos are going down
and
i so i i don't have the appetite for it
or the or the it's like that not the
right frame of mind because because of
the the cultural context which
everything is being taken away
from from children everything is
becoming this also means it's not really
funny because this is like all childhood
everything associated with childhood has
been corrupted and they've done this
with everything so it's not even novel
anymore
and the last
whatever last
remaining
innocent bits of childhood there are
just like leaves them alone and by the
way i'm not saying that they're
destroying my childhood because that
annoys me when adults say that
when something like this happens or
there's some some new version of a show
that they liked when they were kids
comes out oh you're destroying my
childhood
no it's not your childhood your
childhood is over my childhood's been
over for almost two decades so i'm not
worried about my childhood being
destroyed my childhood already happened
and it was not destroyed i'm worried
about
my children's childhood currently being
destroyed that's the issue
so leave winnie the pooh alone
damn you well before you go uh hit the
subscribe button and ring the bell and
while you're at it if you want to go
watch or listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated